out so easily it just shows you don't
have that much stuff well look at the
question that you've been asking me but
where's your self-respect about how much
money do i earn let's say here comes the
money are you saying that man sister
yeah but i've got it's got i've got to
be right you know
dms dating apps i don't have time for
that
i don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe
in grilling them i'm gonna go on a
series of dates to find who
can really wow me this is thrilling
i'm genetically jacked athletically
stacked half man off amazing modern day
max six foot chocolate make you wonder
like stevie fam my name is expressions
losing
you know like that and the girl that's
on this day better not be bothers fam
i'm telling you right now i've had my
heart broken family you know then my day
i'm here to find a proper woman
i'm not trying to see no girl that goes
to the same barbers as me that would be
boring my trainers no size nine foot gal
or nothing like that
if she comes to some boy better no
tracksuit on a bmx but i'm gonna be
fuming in it
i ain't worried about that she better be
worried about me fam i'm chocolate
superman blood you know like that fam
i'm in the nation of domination i'll be
dominating that convoy
take a group da dad you know what shout
out to him he's coming with the right
energy
he said i'm gonna not be a track suit on
a bmx i'll tell you that
yeah man yes bro yeah let me
let me let me let me find some paintings
i'm not losing my words geez
how are you doing oh your hands are nice
and warm yeah softly as well
that headband no just the outfit i was
feeling it but the headband it killed it
killed it
how are you i'm good what's your name
cheyenne just the headband yeah
she would just call it uh yeah she would
call it off what the heck then
80 was good what was wrong with the 20
the headband she won't settle
typical woman my luck is in
listen blood i'm telling you she's going
to the shops i'm buying a packet of hula
hoops fam she could be putting every
ring on my finger black i'm gonna have
more rings than thanos blood hell of
stones blood
telling you john stones out here all the
way from the uk
shout out to expressions oozing i
happened to stumble upon this video and
i said
i know this man i'm a big fan all right
he runs out he runs a channel basically
where he follows uh some some european
football
team called the tottenham space
tottenham can't be looking at a guy like
that undressing me with your eyes
from the moment i sat down and then told
me you're not feeling me blessed
would you say you're an alpha male you
know what a lot of guys like to say oh
i'm an alpha male i'm just starting the
other
what guy has ever told you that half man
half amazing you know i mean i could do
all the things that a man can do
i can do all the things your man won't
do like joe you know them we're dead
right did you earn good money
but earn good money yeah yeah i earned
pretty decent money i'm not even i'm
wearing a gucci headband so we got
let's do some money oh you want to know
how much i earn once i do my accounts
i'll get back to you it's a bit forward
but you're barf still so i allow you
listen
this man said who raised you he said
that question he said it in the most
slick way that wouldn't lose him some
people he said who raised you
like what you [ __ ] first date my [ __ ]
you were on the first date you're done
right but
i don't think that's good though what
did you mean i'm so fresh and so clean
like like andre
three thousand well you know then we're
there but i feel like i can go into my
phone book and show you a text message
from the nhs that says
gonorrhea chlamydia negative but i feel
like out so easily
it just shows you don't have that much
stuff well look at the question that
you've been asking me but where's your
self-respect about how much money do i
earn let's say here comes the money are
you saying that man sister yeah but i've
got
i've got to be right you know
dying business put some respect on my
man's name
this man didn't skip a beat
because i don't like this outfit but if
i did i wouldn't do that for you chill
out bro
you know i've gotta know you're earning
good money a man that can support me
support am i universal credit blood
listen you can stop this [ __ ] right now
this guy wins period you
you you could shut this [ __ ] down right
now he won
or if i was a sex worker what's your
thoughts on that you could be anything
you want to be you just won't be with me
blood
no didn't wait there but why do i want
to be with a porn star like let's be
serious like i'm about only
yeah that's fine because only fans
doesn't everyone thinks only fans is all
a girl robbing what doing that i know
that people can just create only fans
just to have it just have content that
you want private that people have to pay
for
you understand but you subscribe to
mining fans
jeez sorry i i was just like looking at
tea and tamira blood you know then we're
there
sister sister in that way i swear that
top is low fam you know i mean
looking like a low rider in mexico i
know it's difficult when you've got
someone stood there in like a low-cut
top
but a lot of the time i do actually to
test guys i
want to see if they're looking at me and
they're concentrating what i'm saying or
if they're looking at my chest
well that was going great but you lost
me there homie you lost me there
and when they look at what was purposely
there you put it there on a purpose for
them to look at it and when they
actually do
you're mad it's like whenever these
girls hire another girl
to to test their man and when their men
fall for the girl they're mad
bro don't hey listen ladies let me just
give you guys a piece of advice
if you're thinking of testing your man
don't [ __ ] i left high school for a
reason
i didn't come to meet you and go on a
date with you so you put me some more
[ __ ] tests
stop wear which you want to wear but
then don't get mad afterwards when dudes
look like you were purposely trying to
bait them
do you always look at women's boobs on
dates i i look at women's boobs that ask
me how much money i'm earning cross that
line i'll cross it as well
now i mean this girl's putting a chest
and chest and then that blood jeez
getting business what i'm talking about
chest in manchester three
one like i'm i live by the cold don't
start something you ain't got the heart
to finish in it
you know then we're dead there's never
been a thing where i've wanted to pass
my not so so hard i wouldn't dump
together
that's what kind of foolishness you know
them right there but when the world runs
dry like great david but you know i mean
and you just gotta let her know it's
over
that's the point where you uh you you
fill her in and you walk away
hey what you think we don't know about
craig david out here let's go
then the moment you're done with her you
hit up another girl and you set up a
rendezvous
at her place at two you can do anything
you want to do
tenth night is your night oh what do you
think i don't know about craig david
again
listen you don't think i know my craig
david they don't know listen
listen sometimes it's time to do it okay
the artful dodger let's go
rewind i'll play it back sometimes it's
just the time to do it
see these are all the songs on the album
you know how long i listened to that
album for seven years
seven days what makes you exceptional to
be fair yeah when you when i go home and
i look at my birth certificate yeah and
it says chocolate superman it just shows
me in it you know i mean i was always
made
to be something great and you know i
mean chocolate melts in the sun you see
me i tan
i turn into dark chocolate you like
chocolate i do
yeah we like doing we do
they get a bit you know hot fire was
cool made me laugh
the point of grilling someone is to get
them off their engines yeah i mean
because
it's coming he took it he spin it and he
threw it back at her and she was not
expecting that
for a second she was like okay he's
talking about chocolate it's not oh [ __ ]
all right i was not expecting that
boom i feel like i'm a good person are
you a good person yeah
let me ask my friends but your friends
are always going to back you until
you're a good person
i held a charity event in mexico do you
want working with kids but you know in
mexico like a lot of kids get kidnapped
i'm not sure if you've seen the film man
on fire
by denzel washington but a lot of kids
get kidnapped in that and it's really
that's not a good thing in it so i went
over there and i mean my good friends
got a yacht you may know him like he's
very well known his name is pedro
morales
gonzalez you're steaming up my glasses
you know what color is that top
viva la rasa you're making yo this thing
is odd
i don't give a [ __ ] you know what it's
like you know when someone comes to sell
you something and you don't want it
and they start talking all this
gibberish and you have zero interest in
the product but they're so charming
that you like you know what [ __ ] give
me three chicken toes that have been
bathed
in canola oil let's go [ __ ] just give
it to me i'll pay 30 dollars
you have a wonderful day and he leaves
you with a compliment
that makes you think for half a second
that you just didn't get fleeced because
the thing that happened is that this
girl is not even gonna remember
all he said he's gonna people don't
remember all that you say
they remember how you made them feel
he's funny
he's funny he's gonna he he doesn't take
himself seriously but he's not wasting
time with it he's able to flip it
he has a talk he's got my vote this
man's ready for war
if the uk had a had millions of men just
like him during world war ii they
wouldn't have needed the u.s
nope they would have been ready guns
blazing army of chocolate expressions
oozing
let's go
what do you mean i hope you'd like your
beauty
my man's from the island so you already
know what the answer's gonna be if you
want me to see getting yours yes but you
play with mine
listen to me tell them and i'll know it
but not know it burn man burn that man
yo oh it's hulk boat we all talk about
like my man dallas in paris say may not
sell fish me no urchin
what you talking about me no octopus
although me go
octo with the postpost why you talk
about
milo fish me not selfish
me no selfies either so you wouldn't say
that they go fishing
inside places they shouldn't be fishing
they go fishing but they don't go
yeah here in the muddy waters i hear so
they don't go digging for treasures
only treasure me are funny
they're not they're not they're not
exploring your deep seat what deep sema
the only thing
i go deep on is the pom-pom okay so
here they're not there they're not
searching for the titanic
yo the only type of is your pom-pom may
not go in nick
migo and tatanna shout out my med galas
in paris because all
bit was was inspired by alice and
pirates if you if you don't know
galveston paris
go check on the yo gallus in paris we'll
check it out it's great would you say
you're a family man
of course yeah brother it's a family
affair you know i mean like mary j blige
and that trust me i love i love family
yeah yeah what'd you call that on your
head headband i was gonna wear a hat
because i'd match my um trainers and
that but the thing is yeah like i wanted
to show you i'm taking you seriously and
like more time because i do youtube and
people always see me with a house i said
you know what
i've got more waves than a caribbean fan
so let me show her that
put on a little gucci headband you know
then wait there and show her like you
know
i'm making that effort if you like my
outfit that's all right i'm not painting
the headband though
you don't like the headband trying to
take it off i don't know what it is i
don't like it take it off
if you take something off of me why not
i'm not taking anything off
i find like whenever people wear things
with labels it shows that they don't
actually have money you know like when
you're trying to stunt
yeah are you trying to stunt no of
course not you know what my dad
i'm very sure i've got internet banking
i know i got money i hate it when people
wear labels it's like oh
i find people that wear labels don't
have that much money because it's just
you're stunting for what who you trying
to impress i don't like that
that's because you probably live and
hang around broke people i can assure
you
there's a lot of rich people who love
wearing real labels and they take a lot
of joy out of it
yep absolutely and they wear labels in
their cars
in their purses they wear labels they
were lit people wear labels
don't don't
no now you know why yeah no no let me
tell you why
because yeah you need something needs to
attract me for me to chat to someone
don't get me wrong if
if someone's at my bedroom like say i'm
forced into a situation and i'm chatting
to a girl
then i really she's actually a nice girl
but for me say i don't know a girl and i
mean like and i'm just walking i'm in a
club or whatever
i'm not going to see a dead i mean if a
guy looked nice to me and she don't
attract me i'm not going to walk over to
her to find out what her personality is
like
do you understand so there's got to be
something that attracts me
you know what i mean never could be my
banner yeah but what am i going to hear
that what am i just going to be hearing
a girl
well again i'm making some jim carrey
jokes like allowed in a club in that
lesson i think it's a bit shallow
shallow no i can't swim blood so i don't
it makes no difference to me
man the way he deflects the things yo
it's great
but he he's not lying it's like if i
don't know you're you you got a great
personality i might i might miss that
because i'm gonna look at people who are
attractive to begin with right like
especially if i'm just out in public
randomly
so so what he said was exactly on point
she's like well don't you think that's
shallow
shallower don't you think it's crazy
yeah that she has the audacity to be
like
i don't think it's shallow yet she's
the headband killed it for me the
headband
thing is shallow it's the epitome of
shalom like what are you talking about
that's right oh yeah yo she has to be
attractive and you talk about nah i want
to fight that person
whoa stop preaching i just want to make
this clear to y'all
we're not being misogynistic or mean to
her we're just grilling her
what would you do if we were together
and i didn't like your mum
well to be fair
it would be beneficial for you to like
my mum you know then wait there but if
you don't
then you just have to wait in the car
blood you know then wait there when i'm
seeing my mom my mom my queen like she
comes first you'll be sitting in the car
probably build me a spliff or something
like that and then i'll come out then we
can go back to my place like nearly no
anthony hamilton and then people there
and we could just do our thing in it so
you disrespect your mum by being with
someone she didn't like
no my mom doesn't have to know that's
that's foolishness if my mom said if
your mom
no what was the rinky dink ass
correlation that has to do with that
he's not making a choice he's not
choosing you
or his mom he's making what we call in
this world a
compromise it doesn't mean disrespect is
what we call a compromise
so hey listen you my mom you don't like
my mom
that's okay that's your thing i'm not
gonna obligate you to see my mom
but i'm gonna do my thing you could stay
in the car or stay at home
i'm not disrespecting my mom i'm not
going out with my mom
end of story doesn't mean that you're
disrespecting nobody
that is actually a compromise it means
i'm able to see both
without disrespecting both if i bring
you
in the house of my mom it's not going to
be happening i'm not trying to have that
but i'm not trying to not see my mom
compromise so my mom don't know lester
that let's say that mommy mom when you
watch this i hope you're watching this
but i know you love watching my stuff
mom you can't tell me what gal
i can be with don't get me wrong you can
give me your opinion on her
do you know them wait there if my mom
didn't like her for a reason like say oh
she did something that's different
but if my mom just don't like her is she
high blood my mom is laying next to her
you get me my mom make the one having
grandkids with her less so that blood
yeah i mean my mum would like the
grandkids
you know i know i asked the question
about his mum but for me i'm very big on
like
mums and like family so it was a bit
i find it a bit odd that someone would
kind of like date someone their mum
didn't like
because i personally wouldn't date
someone if my parents didn't like them
that's what i did
girl you're you wouldn't date someone
because of their bandana
so i'm not surprised yo this girl's
goofy let me say something man
let's say you were to fall for somebody
y'all y'all have the same values
you share the same ideas it's already
hard enough dating as well you meet
someone that works
okay they have the right ideas you're
gonna date for a while before the
parents are involved
and then my mom comes to the picture
doesn't like you and i'm what supposed
to dump you because she's got bad tastes
you're the bright person in my head to
raise my kids
do you think that my parents are
infallible my parents are perfect they
they know everything they've always made
the right choices so i'm supposed to
dump the person who i think is right to
raise my children
because because your mom doesn't like
them yo
yo listen yeah this girl's bugging i
think we're quite comparable we wanted
similar things when it was like the
compatibility round
which was good and he seems like he's a
family man he's got good morals
however i do want to see what's in his
dms though red flags
her asking me how much money i earned i
thought it was clear blood just look at
me
you know them wait they're fat i think
everything was perfect everything was
great apart from the double standard and
for me i'm very big on that
so that's probably the only downside to
the date don't get me wrong
some of the questions were forwarding
that but if she can ask me that that
means i can ask her that blood
you get me i can check her body count
fan i liked his confidence
i thought he smelled nice well boy
you're gonna have to give her
an additional number black because 10
it's too low blood i feel like i'm going
to deduct a point for that headband
because it was actually all four
10 teen time i told you already not 10
not 11 not 12
not 13 10 teen blood that's what she's
going to give me
actually i would have deducted another
point because you keep all labels for me
like it's i hate it whether people wear
labels like them other man on the day
no disrespect to them because big
yourselves up in that but you mana
halloumi cheese
your coleslaw blood you're corn on the
cob fam i'm state blood yeah
i'm the primary man here fam you know
then we're there i move faster black i'm
sin by blood i'm everywhere
i'm gonna give him a 7.5
[Music]
you're telling me that you removed the
headband and the fact that he was
wearing a givenchy shirt
he would be at 9.5 that's what you're
telling me
okay he wrote here 7.5
am i a prick no i'm fueling [ __ ]
[Music]
i appreciate it i i i actually like
hearing this because it's cool
interesting here i like
how dudes with the game in other
countries sound it sounds different than
out here you feel me
yeah definitely but this guy's special
he's pretty it was dope that's pretty
dude awesome
i really enjoyed it so if you guys liked
hearing him if you thought he was funny
go check him out
he got videos that he runs on his own
channel here on youtube
even if you don't like soccer the man is
funny i think he should run his own
channel
for just football but yeah and then just
for
also his community says he's hilarious
but yeah go check him out
and uh that's pretty much it what do you
think about uk slang you a big fan
i love it [ __ ] love it [ __ ]
i love everything about it it's it's you
know wall it's it's just
it's just bulldogs mate i love it
it's it's it's now it's badass it's nice
i like it i like the difference
that they have different different
places depending on where they are if
they're more urban if they're less
european
they still have a slice that's dope even
like the company [ __ ] it's dope
[ __ ] i like i like this lens i like the
culture
yeah i really like it yo there's mad
pink black
[Applause]
[Music]
your girls
ah
[Music]
hold on